He did toilet seats.
The first time I went to Japan and try to heat the toilet seats. I'm just like,
how is the rest of the first world cut? Like other first world countries have.
Yeah, I won't lie. I think I have actually ruined toilets to myself.
Cause whenever I go to a toilet, now that doesn't have a bad day,
I legit feel like I'm having a panic attack. I legit feel like,
how am I supposed to wash my? Clean, wipe it. Are you kidding me?
I'm not an animal. I don't touch that area. Do I,
if I haven't moved back to the UK, no joke. I'm a hundred percent.
The suitcase is empty, dude.
I'm making room for the premium $1,000 a day because I'm using that daily.
I want to like a King. And like,
I remember prosey D I was talking to him as well. One time he was like, dude,
when he went back from when he came back from Japan,
the one thing he brought was a bad day for real, because he was like,
I insist he has taste, man. He was arguing. He's like,
I insist that I like a King. And I'm like, honestly, I completely understand it.
Cause once you get used to a bad day and you get the heated seat, you know,
you get the, you get a little pressure washer. You can have it set to like,
boom, boom, boom, boom. They go back and forth on your cheeks. It's nice. Yeah.
I might ask for you to permanently clean.
Why wouldn't I want a shower for my every time I should. Like,
are you kidding me? Sometimes I don't even, but I do it cause I'm like,
why don't you.
Clean my? I know I got full time.
I want to make my feel refreshed because you know, sometimes right, man,
you have those days where like it's a hot day. You get like swamp pass.
You know what I mean? We you're asked, just gets kind of sweaty.
It's not even bad, but just a little bit. You're like, why not just click it?
[Inaudible] okay. I completely missed on this. It's just like,
you're not talking about it.
Heated. The heated seat is also amazing,
but you're talking about because the [inaudible] and the heated seats,
part of the payday package, right? Even the cheapest one. Okay.
I don't use the washing washing day at all.
it just, it just doesn't feel clean. I don't know.
Cleanest thing in the toilet. It does not. I like, are you kidding me?
Okay. So you, so this going to space with me, like yeah. I never looked up
[inaudible] right.
But the water shooting up your and then you stop here and then you just got to.
You just go, you just got wet.
She gets some of the toilet paper and you just dry it a little bit.
You dry it off.
Yeah. Because like you need the toilet paper,
but it doesn't feel clean without that wipe.
Yeah. But okay. But some of them, that's what you have to watch.
Some of them have dryers and those are pretty good.
No, no, no. I have. You tried. Have you tried? I have tried. I have.
No, no, no. Okay. Yeah,
because this is a difference between wiping to dry or why are we talking about
this? It's a different soup. Why pizza? Dry your and wiping to get the out.
Yeah. They're very different types of wipes.
Right? One is, one is like a deep.
Excavation is a Pat down. Look.
Look, toilet papers were not designed to wipe wet arses. No,
because you're asking us.
This. Isn't the like Amazon river dude. It's a, it's a little moisture. What.
I hate is when, when you have a wet after day, you go to,
you got to wipe it and the toilet paper just disintegrates on your house.
You like using how much,
how much water can your in blessable position contained. And second of all,
toilet paper. Why are you using God? Why are you using one ply sandpaper?
What are you using to absorb? You got to use the double, double minimum.
Come on. What I will supply.
How many sheets of paper is used in it? Easy. Like one square and be like.
It doesn't matter.
And anyone who lives in Asia knows that toilet paper here is weak as
is you sound broke right now gone. [inaudible] I thought like,
cause I thought he was just,
it was just a tie thing where toilet paper was just like flacid. No,
I moved to Japan and toilet paper here is like weakened. You can't buy the good.
Yeah. You get the Double-Play.
And then you do like maybe like one wrap around your hand.
That's more than enough to absorb any amount of liquid that's down to pile on
three little sheets. Right? That's a nice thickness to it. Right.
That to at least like that. And then just get onto that one rip. Good.
And your is clean and it's dry. I cannot believe you would come here. Like,
cause honestly, but days in the top three things about Japan,
I'm going to be honest with you. He didn't told us seats, but days the hook,
your whole experience, top three, the whole toilet experience,
like a top three Japanese thing for me, man. Like it's just great. Okay.
I'll look forward. Another thing about bodies as well.
Like it shoots up right up your. All right. That's exactly what I want.
And then you just feel like you have your you're out water.
And so like keep this
water stuck in your or
are you like giving yourself like a prostate massage on a bit daily?
It just like, which is not because they get bought a stuck in your Amos.
How do you do that? It's your,
you are you, are you putting your all over the body? Are you,
are you putting it?
Putting the hose in the stream of water is the strong enough?
You probably sent it to like pressure hose, public fountain.
Because if it's not strong, then it's just a trick on your.
And that's not cleaning up shoes called medium.
You need the pressure to clean that up.
But if it has enough pressure to clean the off your,
then you're getting water stuck in your
[inaudible] is on the max pressure. And it's perfect because,
because you can feel the coming off. And I mean, I don't know about you,
but my is knocking ironclad right here, man. Clench,
clench that you know, cleaning it properly when you're,
what do you mean? You're not cleaning it properly when you clench
clench. When you clench, when you day that. I said like,
look her up a little bit. God is like,
God is like, relax. My owners allow the water to flow in.
Like you're giving yourself a like,
[inaudible] it feels like I'm getting it. I'll take a big day.
Enema every time it's totally wrong. Because like,
I don't clench when I. What do you mean? What are you just like?
I let gravity do its work fun. Slip. The slides
[inaudible] we might clench. You would just mean push. Yeah. Punch.
That's the same thing.
Normally that kid that doesn't help with the day still goes up the. Even,
even if you push that.
Out, the anatomy of your, I.
Need it. We need an x-ray of your day cam just to see like what,
like how loose your all is when he gets to the date. Like,
I just don't like the feeling of like water on my. And I dunno.
What about in the shower? What are you cleaning your with? No. Okay. So you,
you know, you know, when you clean your gone, I cleaned my.
You talked about the sweaty,
you talking about the sweaty fitting and your swamp pass. If I guess one pass,
I just take a shower.
So unnecessary. I can take, I can take three showers takes one.
It goes home. He's like, got a shower now.
Honestly, honestly like sometimes if I want to feel clean after a,
I just take a shower, man. Quick five quick, five minute.
What are you doing in these toilet? You're like you gone gone is that one too.
Usually when you leave some public restrooms, it's like a war zone.
I must be gone. That that is not the everywhere. on the wall. It's like,
that is gone.
It's gone going in the place in places you didn't think would end on.
It's the opposite, man. Why would I use it day when I can't reach my kids?
Like my are like the cleanest. You know? They, they are,
there's no such thing as a clean. Have you never had like the perfect?
You know, like the no wipes. Yeah. Like, like this is perfect. The perfect,
which was just like, you just shoot out a log and it's like one solid clean log.
And then you look at it and it's like, no wipe, you look at it.
And you're just like, man, I that's a piece of art right there in my family.
We call that the swish because it doesn't touch the sides.
[Inaudible].
Yeah. I just did a Swisher over there, man.
You don't need a day after you did that swish, man. I mean,
I still like it though. I still do it anyway because it feels good to me.
The equivalent right. Of coming to Japan and just being like, yeah man,
I just ate only KFC and burger King. It's like,
you've wasted the true potential of Japan. Like what have you done? Like you,
you, it, it is, it is on Paul, honestly with food, something about Japan,
like food's amazing. And the experience is also goblin.
I actually look forward to taking a call white, to crack open the per day.
Crack, crack, open a the day with the boys soccer from the blue day.
Just have a great time.
Yeah. for pleasure. Honestly.
I used to ship because there's a bodily function.
Now I look forward to my cause it's Chapin and they've they figured out how to
make and enjoyable.
I look forward to shooting for like other reasons. Like the day is just like
[inaudible]. Yeah. W well, one I have Walmart
and there's like two sacred places for me. And one is the shower. And the other one is when I'm taking
a right now, probably probably like my channel wouldn't it
wouldn't exist. If I couldn't share a shower
, where the am I going to get my ideas for it? You're having a
existential crisis on the toilet. Yes I am. Who doesn't do you not know
? Because taking your for me is enjoyable. I have a great
that's the reason like people think that I take such a long time to because I'm having like a mental breakdown
time. No, I'm just having a great time. I'm just like, why would I leave early
when I'm having this much fun right here. It's so fun. I love, but days are just, I
don't know. In, in Thailand we have like an even worse
thing, which is like, it's, it's, it's like, it's like a self pay
day, right? So in like most Southeast Asian countries, we don't have like the auto on your
per
days. We have like a little like a shower head, like a mini shower head that you have to like put between your legs. Some European countries have that
suit. Right?
The whole bowl. The thing that like the little bowl next to it,
or you do it in the toilets.
It's like the little bolting ball in the toilet. And at that point, like,
I dunno, I've always hated that feeling. Cause then you just get wet bulls.
That's too much because the day is precise with where it's at. Right.
And when you've used your own, V-Day long enough.
But the days like sniping your eyes, you know,
when you know where it's going to go. Yeah.
The radius of which it'll spread. So you've got it down to not right.
Like we talked about,
how long have you been talking about showering are.
I've always wanted to talk about on the podcast because it's one of the no joke,
the most enjoyable parts of Japan. I know what to call it.
So now the Japanese toilet experience, the Japanese experience.
I know where golden record experience comes from now.
And it's it's when you're on the toilet.
Did you get, like, what did, were you a bit like bored when you first saw how.
Operate the other day when you first came to Japan?
I think a lot of British people are because it's like the thought of spraying
your is so foreign to us. Yeah.
What was the thing that you and Alan did again?
The first time you went to the hotel with him?
How the day knew when you were sitting on it? The bathroom was like a wet room.
So we were like, okay, well, does it matter if it's per day sprays everywhere?
And so we were, we had like a few drinks. We were like,
let's figure out how the day works. So we figured out the day won't spray,
unless there's pressure on the seat is pretty cool. Yeah.
And then it was like spraying on the wall. Cause no one was sitting there.
Oh, this thing was going, Oh, it was spraying. Oh yeah. That's the pressure.
That's the pressure.
The story of [inaudible] house in Australia, we always had a bad day.
Cause my mom was like, I can't live without a bad day. So sorry.
Because she's Japanese and she's like a King. She's like a peasant.
Let me teach you Australians. How to like a King. So we had it in our,
in our house. But of course when I was little, I didn't use the bad day. Right.
Because I didn't know what the I was. I was just like, Oh, buttons.
But I didn't, I didn't press any of them.
I remember first time seeing him for a day and I'm just like, yo, do I need,
do I need a license to operate this? He's like,
I feel like if I, if I personally want a button,
like this toilet is gonna take off, like here,
here is like the operating system of the day that you can see on screen right
now. Especially like going to Japan the first time.
And it's the wind in the day when I was little, like,
I never knew how to use the day. Right. Cause I didn't,
I was just learned to like,
just make sure to wipe and wash your hands and then you'll be good.
But you know, when you get to like around like age six or seven,
you start to get a little bit curious what these buttons I'll use this. Like,
I wonder what this is. So I did the fatal mistake though. So I pushed the,
the day I started the day by,
but I made the fatal mistake getting up off of my seat and looking down at the
toilet bowl spray. So sprayed me in the eye.
And this is water going everywhere. And I'm like, I don't know how to stop this,
what the happening. I actually thought I broke my toilet.
So I called my mom and I was just like, mom, come here.
So she came in Budae water going everywhere in this toilet.
And then the last thing she said, like, she finally stopped it. And she's like,
you could have at least like flushed your, man.
So the day water is also warm. So it is literally like a warm shower.
Only double use only. And your thing is right, is that, you know,
if you're an American or your just a westerner in general and you come and you
see this toilet. Yeah. It can be daunting. Right. Because you know,
normally things don't go near your. You're not used to that. Just embrace it.
It feels good. You know, it's scary. But once you,
once you admit the things feel good when they spray your,
like discovering.
A new fetish, it's like, just give it.
A go. It's like, does it feel a little erotic?
Yeah, it does. But you know, if it feels good,
the wet afterwards just doesn't feel good.
It.
Doesn't feel clean. I dunno, my doesn't feel properly.
Like I don't feel properly clean after a wipe.
I feel like 90% clean after a while. Cause you know,
there's always gonna be a little bit left. Right. Right. You know,
that day is scraping that.
Washing your hands without soap. It's like, you might feel clean,
but you don't really, until you use that soap,
I know I need to physically feel my being clean and not like getting it washed.
I don't know. I need to feel that, man. I need to confirm with my own hands.
That's what you should do.
You should use the per day and then wipe it with your hand and see if it's still
good. Because like, it doesn't feel properly cleaned to me unless I shower.
Like my also never feels clean and that's my shower. And I probably soap in it.
This man is like wasting buckets of water to clean his office.
I only could just be using a bad day.